لقد صادفنا للتو غرفة هنا
في مجمع المساجد مليئة
بالفتيات الصغيرات اللائي
يدرسن لكنهن لا يدرسن الرياضيات
والعلوم ، بل يدرسن القرآن ،
فهل تذهب الفتيات إلى المدرسة العادية
أيضًا
في يوليو
[موسيقى] ،
لا ، لا ، لا يفعلون '  لا أذهب إلى المدرسة هنا فقط ،
هل يمكنني أن أسأل لماذا لا يذهبون إلى المدرسة
[موسيقى]
يفعلون كل شيء هنا ولا
يريدون الذهاب إلى هناك ،
نؤكد ذلك للناس في جميع أنحاء
العالم وخاصة شعب
أفغانستان
الذي قدمه الإسلام  حقوق لكل فرد على
قدم المساواة ،
للمرأة حقوقها الخاصة ،
كم منحت الإسلام حقوقًا للمرأة
، سنمنحها هذا القدر حتى
أخبرنا المحافظ والمسجد أنه
سيتم تعليم الفتيات الآن بعد أن
تغير طالبان ولكن هذا المعلم
أخبرنا بذلك للتو.  الفتيات يتلقين
تعليمًا دينيًا فقط
[موسيقى
] لقد تحدثت إلى بعض النساء
في هذه الغرفة ووعدت أنني
لن أظهر أيًا من وجوههن ، لكن
هذا مثير للاهتمام لأنك تعرف أن
طالبان تتحدث كثيرًا عن كيفية
تغيرها  يمكن للفتيات g  يا إلى المدرسة الآن
ولكني سألت إذا كانت أي من هؤلاء الفتيات
ستذهب إلى المدرسة وقيل لي على
الإطلاق أن
الفتيات لا يذهبن إلى المدرسة وعندما قلت
لماذا لا تذهب الفتيات إلى المدرسة قالوا إن
طالبان تقول إنها سيئة